uh in fact gonna get busier this weekend
because on sunday the las vegas raiders
are back at death star home opener at
allegiant against arizona cardinals so
as pro sports grow here in las vegas so
does sports betting which has been going
on for as long as we can remember
obviously especially among women candace
charles live this morning at allegion
stadium with a closer look at that
candice good morning to you
good morning you two good morning folks
just a short to be exciting weekend and
a packed one here at elysian stadium for
the first home opener game for the las
vegas raiders and i hear that las vegas
raiders are having a good season for
betting that's according to action
network news now of course we're also
hearing that women are getting in on the
sports betting guys so you're going to
watch out more than 4.6 million women
signed up for sports book apps in 2021 a
growth of 115 year over year now that's
according to a recent study by global
wireless solutions and we've seen that
growth here in vegas both westgate and
circle reports seeing more women get in
on sports betting downloading apps like
pro pickums experts say it's simple to
play and with the access to more content
easy to learn the rules of the game
being you know a general education of
women
uh in the sports betting space as well
as you know the stigma uh going away
from it make up half of the nfl fan base
and so it makes sense why they would
want some skin in the game just like men
do
well remember that timing is everything
when it comes to sports betting if
you're planning to put your money on the
raiders get on it you know i haven't
gotten in on sports betting yet my
brother's been trying to get me in on it
for quite some time but you know what i
may have to give it a try and coming up
i got a few tips for you guys so you
guys will want to tune back in to check
that out of course the game kicks off
here at 1 25 on sunday stick with us for
the latest for now candice charles 8
news now